Good morning, Jarvis.
Good morning, Mark.
It's Saturday, so you only have five meetings.
Room temperature is set to a cool 68 degrees.
Earlier this year, I started building a simple AI to help run our home.
I talk to Jarvis using this app I built.
It uses artificial intelligence to understand me and figure out what to do.
Max woke up a few minutes ago.
I'm entertaining her.
Alright, let's go check on her.
Good morning, Max.
Let's practice our Mandarin.
Jarvis, your Mandarin is so soothing.
Jarvis also helps me get ready in the morning.
Fresh shirt!
Fire in the hole!
Hell yeah!
Jarvis knows when to make me breakfast.
Your toast is ready.
Alright!
It's time for my call with Schroep.
Can you get him on the video conference line?
Setting up the VC room now.
Remember to check on the AI guidance system for Aquila.
One of the best things about Jarvis is it could recognize people at the gate,...
...let them in automatically and then just tell me about it.
Mark, your parents are coming in.
Thanks, Jeffrey.
It's Jarvis.
And Jarvis can play all of our favorite music.
Hey, play us some good Nickelback songs.
I'm sorry, Mark.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
There are no good Nickelback songs.
And if I don't want to talk, I can just text Jarvis through a messenger bot that I built.